again across this administration
everything inevitably is about the the
notion that
inequality and inequity are exactly the
same thing
and this is being in and your kids are
being indoctrinated with this so unc
chapel hill is now giving out mandatory
woke training
according to hot air
the university of north carolina at
chapel hill recently held a mandatory
training session for all greek
organizations on campus carolina review
the campus conservative newspaper got
leaked audio from the training and also
spoke to people who attended
apparently the person who was speaking
here
whose name is paul
started a presentation with an
indigenous land recognition after which
hundreds of greek attendees were advised
they should make a habit of repeating
the political catechism in their daily
lives and taught how to do so after
establishing her lecture was on stolen
land powell asked students their
feelings about the system were they
warmed toward it apathetic or ready to
dismantle it
at this point parle started talking
about the role of identity and the
social constructs which defined them a
subject which introduced the
presentation and remained a focal point
throughout
she emphasized that identity is a
primary factor in life experience
explaining that identity guides the way
you navigate the world and students were
instructed to write their intersectional
identities like sex and race and sexual
orientation and body size
on a piece of paper and here's what it
sounded like
it means that every grocery store
literally almost approximation was built
for the average type person
experience service
and all of you
experience oppression in some way being
personal right should you feel guilty
for your privilege
how are you going to use it for good
okay i'm sorry this is insanity but this
again this goes back to the idea that
any disparity is some form of she
literally says in this presentation
okay this is not now because i'm
discussing a woke training session at
unc chapel hill this is what barack
obama would call a culture war that is
fake outrage okay except that it goes to
the heart of left-wing ideology right
now this lady is speaking to it she
literally says that if you have to reach
for the top shelf
at a grocery store because you can't
reach it you have to have somebody else
to help you have suffered oppression
right every single person in the room
she says has benefited from oppression
and suffered from oppression because the
world was built for the average
okay so i just have a question who else
would it be built for what is her
proposed solution
should we have
presumably the the
height of the shelves because it's built
for the average person should it be
built for the lowest common denominator
presumably that means that all shelves
at the grocery store should only be
about three foot five high
and you'd have to lease twice the space
at the grocery store in order to fit
everything you'd have to have a much
much bigger store in order to be able to
even lay out the goods so so that nobody
has to take the horrifying step of
asking a person who works at the store
or a person walking down the aisle to
reach something for them by the way
i'll just note here that actually
it creates a sort of communal comedy the
fact that people have to ask each other
for help sometimes that's not the end of
the world
i was a target the other day and there
was a lady there and she lost her
glasses and she couldn't read the label
on the bottom of a lamp that she wanted
to buy so she asked me for help
and i read it for her and we kind of
smiled at each other we moved on that
wasn't a bad thing she wasn't oppressed
but but the idea here again is that all
structures of oppression are bad and how
are you going to dismantle them
okay that's not a mild cultural issue
it has ramifications for everything
across all areas of american life and
this is how you end up with videos from
buzzfeed about how you have six separate
genders and if society doesn't take into
account six separate genders that's
because society is oppressive
when you get to the point where
everybody's subjective identity is
supposed to be accepted celebrated and
built for by the society
then you can't have a society at all
because literally this stuff is
subjective it changes on a moment's
notice you have no objective way of
verifying any of that you can't
construct a society the point is the
chaos the point is the confusion it is
the same as the gobbledygook that is
being spewed by this administration in
justification of radical economic policy
it is all part of the same deal
which is that there will be no objective
reality to which we all answer that will
just disappear into the ether and any
objective reality is a form of
oppression it is a form of oppression if
somebody doesn't accept that you call
yourself a unicorn
it is a form of oppression if you have
to reach for the top shelf and it is a
form of oppression if there is one group
of people in the united states that is
poorer than another group of people in
the united states and you don't even
have to look at whether there is a
disparity between how people in one
group
act in the aggregate not individually in
the aggregate you don't have to look at
the historic circumstances and you don't
have to look at whether the corrective
to that might be more of a problem than
the actual problem itself
is here's how
in terms of gender it manifests just
complete gobbledygook sheer insanity
here we go from this insane buzzfeed
video
what is your gender i identify female i
am
male for me there's a little bit of a
difference um between gender and gender
expression i would say my is it femi i
can't say the word
my gender is feminine i was born
anatomically scientifically a doctor who
liked a girl but as i grew up i was like
that doesn't really work for me i feel
like i'm a more masculine person like
this like a system i was with
like i know i think i would classify as
that as well but i'm just like
i'm so uneducated yeah i guess i never
questioned it either to be honest with
you so
it's a matter of education right it's a
matter of indoctrination i'm just
uneducated none of these people know
what they're talking about because it's
complete nonsense but the idea is that
if all of reality is not reconstructed
to fit their particular identity then
society itself is oppressive
there is no more you cannot have a
society this way
what you can have is sheer
sheer tyranny you can have people who
are empowered to fix every problem in
american life and protect you from the
vicissitudes of an actual real world
that is not that is going to bite back
against you see this is the stupidity of
all this we can play this naval gazing
game where we pretend that all of these
systems of reality no longer apply
because we become so wealthy and so fat
maybe we can do that but eventually
reality will win because reality is
still out there reality is still reality
if we decide that just as a society
we're going to embrace stupidity
societies that don't embrace stupidity
are going to benefit and flourish in the
reality that exists
and those ones will overtake us it is
that simple people who deny reality lose
societies that deny reality lose
i root for reality because i think that
reality always wins anyway it's like
rooting for the yankees eventually
they're always going to win
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content